[Music]
yourself and be fearless because you're
not gonna get anywhere if you don't just
like break through what you're scared of
doing
[Applause]
she can really open up anyone to help
them achieve what they want and believe
in themselves and I think that's so
important how I consider myself breaking
free by showing everybody how I feel on
the inside
rabid red hair that's seen better days
goggles that have cheap gems on them but
still look great you have to do what you
wanted to regardless of your financial
gains or losses
perfection is what I've always wanted in
life but I learned that as I kept going
the less perfect it got the better it
looked when you compare yourself to
other people you're not being true to
yourself you're only you like Gaga says
you were born this way so if just being
who you want to beat because that leads
you to greater things I think when that
song came out I was going first and
stuff and just hearing that throughout
the day just really reminded me of it
I'm an okay person and I need to be
happy with who I am and it really helped
me a lot it's about being who you want
to be with no boundaries it's not easy
to break free but it's critical to break
free it's critical to follow our hearts
creativity is the greatest form of
rebellion live every day like it's the
best day of your life
[Applause]
[Music]